bienvenue à tous dans ce cercle des
femmes j'avais envie de vous parler
d'une méthode pour vous passer des
serviettes hygiéniques pendant les
règles tu vas où victor un bas j'ai
entendu que c'était le cercle des femmes
moi je croyais que c'était l'atelier
lâcher prise donc donc tu penses que les
règles ça concerne téléphone non j'ai
pas dit ça
mais effectivement c'est plus un
problème de femme as un problème non
c'est bien que tu restes oui d'accord
c'est parce que je passe est une
expression d' accor propose qu'on chante
[Musique]
justement je pratique déjà l'évacuation
naturel alors c'est sûr j'ai encore
quelques coulées intempestivement
j'apporte plus les règles du tout de la
même manière et ouais je me suis mis à
les aimer je les attends j'ai même hâte
que ça arrive moi pour mes selles
[Musique]